this is the picturesque village of old
aunt olive eat pork near adis I'm in the
state of rheinland-pfalz it's home to
four hundred year old grapevines when
the grapes are right the Pickers head
for the water hose and garden vineyard
it's one of the oldest vineyards in the
world six hundred square meters in size
and it has just three rows of vines
vintner stefan oberhofer invests a lot
of time in the vineyard in an endless
cycle of weeding pruning and cutting the
hard work ensures that the ancient vines
will flourish for a few more years that
one with you it's difficult getting any
kind of yield at all look at this little
one this one it's always exciting in the
old vineyard it's over 400 years old
some of today's vines only last 20 to 25
years and the fact that this one is
still standing is pretty miraculous the
300 Trevino vines which are believed to
have been planted in the early 17th
century have been under a preservation
orders since nineteen sixty eight
various Wars have passed them by and
thanks to their tough bark and roots
they survived the ravages of the
grapevine louse might have been mindful
eating now on shout if you take a closer
look pokes it you can see that the stalk
and bark have cracked open I wound up
these nothing but help no they're hollow
in the middle it's amazing that this
vine is still producing fruit it's at
Moss for years and it's pretty gnarly
and twisted it Ralph Niska boxin when I
stunts whole month knowledge
this picture shows how the vineyard
might have looked in the early 19th
century the vines belong to the zaire
family for decades before they became
the property of the Oberhofer estate to
in the early 1970s it was purchased 40
years ago by the father of the current
vendor the hunt is on Fox Allen be in
the early days we used a horse for
plowing did the rest by hand when all
this meat on a light all the manual work
means things are very labor-intensive
but this venerable old fellow he
deserves it the annual harvest depends
entirely on the weather the 2006 harvest
for example produced just three buckets
of grapes
2009 was a little better Oberhofer made
400 liters of wine from that harvest
still he hopes to get a few bottles from
the current crop so but whether it's a
bumper crop or a bust every year Heidi
Oberhofer holds a kind of thanksgiving
event it's become a tradition
the male provides some extra
fortification for the team before they
get to work the wine from the old
aromatic Gewurztraminer vines makes up
less than 1% of the vineyards total
production it's a labor of love for
Stefan Oberhofer and he's delighted with
the reading on the ERKs lyst scale that
gives it a laser steps excellent quality
connoisseurs say this Gewurztraminer has
a more mature taste than others of its
kind now all the Oberhofer family can do
is wait and see what the next harvest
brings